that Eric Adams changed his tune even
the Liberals on The View they're
changing their tune too this issue
will destroy
city the city we
we're about to lose
but frankly you know I think we need to
find and we've dealt with this before I
I lived in uh in Miami I was a migrant
an immigrant in Miami in the 80s you'll
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift yeah 125 000 Cubans came in a
matter of six months it puts tremendous
stress on on on a city on a community on
the social services they need to be
resettled elsewhere
I thought the immigrants were our
strength I thought We're a nation of
immigrants New York's a city the more
immigrants the better but then Eric
Adams mayor of New York changed his tune
and now all the other Liberals are
changing their tune too why because Anna
Navarro knows that she's on the same
team as Eric Adams